hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're going to
be going over the dutch defense and
that's defense is a defense against the
queen pawn opening which is why it's
opening move of d4 and as I've talked in
different videos you want to have a few
different defenses that you can use
against any wide opening for instance
you need to have a couple defenses that
you know pretty well against the Pawnee
for opening against the the English
opening the the c4
and the very popular d4 pawn opening
that we're going to go over today so
there are definitely many options today
we're going to be going over the Dutch
defense which is just pawn to f5 and if
you've never studied it it may look a
little odd to you but it actually plays
pretty well and gives black quite a
quite a good amount of counter attack
especially on the kingside as you can
imagine here we're already starting to
to pawn storm the the King side and what
black does from the very beginning is
attack the the center with one of his
pawns it's not on the E or d square in
this case it's the the F pawn now
obviously blacks key weakness Square at
the beginning of any matches the pawn on
the f7 Square but we're basically taking
that pawn in attacking immediately the
the center me for white would obviously
like to play e4
right away to gain center control but we
have taken that option away obviously he
can gambit this away and give it to us
for free
but we are staking Center control and I
actually like to play this every now and
then it kind of has that feel if you're
used to playing the Kings gambit as
white it basically you you're opening up
this F file eventually you'll you'll get
rid of this F pawn hopefully do some
damage with it but then once you Castle
kingside you'll have this rook nicely
placed on the F file and as with the
King's gambit you're down to pieces
black here you never really go down and
material so to be even in material for
me and to have a rook nicely placed on a
semi-open
F file once this pawn is going in the
rook and kind of rain down on the King
side I actually like this defense and
also just because watch it's not too
familiar with it as far as how to how to
counter seeing the Dutch a lot of people
play you know the Queens gambit accepted
lines the Queens gambit declined lines
but a lot of people don't play the Dutch
so a couple different variations that
you will see from here many many times
white will fianchetto their Bishop on
the King side so a lot of times you'll
see why bring their Bishop two to g2
after their pawn is developed to the g3
square or a lot of times you'll you'll
see why just merely come to the the c-4
square kind of the backwards English
opening and then they'll bring their
knight to the c3 score after their their
pawn is on the c4 square but either way
it doesn't really matter the moves I
kind of like and I'll kind of give you
background on why I usually plan first
one is just going to be e six and it's a
here we'll go ahead and choose move for
white here we'll say he fianchetto is
bishop first move I like his ecigs as I
said and the reason I like this is
twofold
one it keeps white from continuing to
march down my throat here at d5
obviously white can obviously come to c4
and then try to push up it also gives a
little bit of protection to this f7
square y can always fianchetto as bishop
and then bring it along this diagonal
here but we right now have a little
defense from the e6 square so as you can
see since we have this pawn on e6 our
light square bishop here on c8 more than
likely is going to come to this b7 to g2
diagonal is going to come to this long
diagonal here obviously it's only going
to happen once the fianchettoed Bishop
is blocked off maybe by the knight or
something but more than likely since our
LightSquared bishop is blocked off here
you need to notice where your your
bishops are going to go so if he's
blocked off he's not going to go this
way for the time being so we'll go and
continue and look at the the different
lines here so white fianchetto this is
bishop and from here i like bringing the
the knight to f6
it obviously develops another minor
piece your minor pieces are your bishops
and your knight it adds more pressure to
the e4 square obviously white has an
attacker here on the the e4 square with
his bishop and now we have two attackers
on the e4 square with our pawn and our
knight and you can already see we kind
of have an attack coming down on the
King side
so why can't continue play here he can
he can bring his nine to the action he
can bring his pawn into the action see
four you'll see a lot and from here I
just like the simple move Bishop to e7 a
lot of times you'll see black bring his
Bishop try to pin our Knight to the
Queen so even if he does that doesn't
matter I like to bring our Bishop to the
e7 square I feel like it's a good place
and also at the same time it's being
developed and we can castle next move
and have a safe place for our King and
then like I said before our rook is on
this nice long F file that we can can
rain down so you can already see from
here the from here you might see white
go Knight to c3 and just look in here
you can kind of see see the themes that
we have going on here
White has a little better center control
he's got two pawns here on the C and D
square basically controlling
on the on the fifth-ranked here along
with his Knight and his Bishop obviously
White's going to bring his knight to
either f3 or e2 he's going to Castle
kingside and he's got a lot of centre
control black does not he's got some sub
pawns here on the E in the F files along
with his knight but he doesn't have
quite this inner control that white does
but also Black has started to come down
and attack slightly on the on the King
side of white so keep that in mind like
I said before obviously we will want to
we'll want to bring our knight into the
action we can always pause storm the
Queen side so if you want to build up an
attack obviously you want to be careful
and not make a move like b6 and open up
your your rook here but you can always
you know you can even break it open with
a move like c5 your your Bishop on e7 is
protecting this piece just kind of give
some center center protection there you
can decide which way you want to bring
your Queen into the action more than
likely it's going to come to the Queen
side he's kind of blocked off on the
King side but you definitely have a lot
of different options there are few more
variations later on in videos I'm going
to go over those but these are some of
the key concepts a lot of people like to
fianchetto their their King Bishop to
the g7 square but this is kind of how I
like to play the Dutch defense and this
is kind of why I like to play it and how
I like to play it so I hope this helped
a little bit for those looking for a
little bit analysis on the Dutch defense
hope you guys enjoy please subscribe to
the videos helped out a lot leave
comments concerns anything you want to
to know about learn about
and check out other videos let me know
what you think and chest out check out
the website and I'll see you guys next
video thanks a lot